today is July 12th which means that
Amazon and Netflix and reddit and a
bunch of other companies are protesting
against the rollback of net neutrality
by the Donald Trump FCC I have been
telling you for months that one of the
foremost issues of 2017 in the Trump era
is an issue that impacts all political
issues and that is that the Trump FCC
and former Verizon lawyer Ajit PI who
runs the FCC and Congress want to
rollback the Internet freedom laws that
were passed under President Barack Obama
this includes the regulation of Internet
service providers as common carriers
under title 2 of the Telecommunications
Act sort of like a telephone company and
it includes a number of other provisions
Amazon Netflix Reddit and others today
are prominently displaying alerts about
what's happening with net neutrality
there were rumors that some of them
might actually throttle service and slow
down service with a note making it clear
sort of like this is what it could be
like if net neutrality provisions are
rolled back and one of the main concerns
is that ISPs could create fast lanes and
slow lanes on the internet corresponding
with companies or services or websites
that they want to either support or hurt
now I hope that they if they do the
throttling they will make it very clear
what is going on because there's
probably some kind of business risk
there right you just slow down your
website nobody knows it's this day of
action on net neutrality and you think
Oh
Netflix is just really crappy now I'm
sure that they will make it very clear
what they're doing right it's one thing
when Netflix does it which is primarily
an entertainment website Amazon does it
I mean whole businesses will have
negative repercussions from that net
neutrality in total is good for people
and it's actually good for most
businesses and this is a dangerous cliff
that we're approaching on this issue the
cliff that the right tells us we're
approaching on Obamacare it doesn't
exist as I told you yesterday this cliff
is real okay we're at the intersection
of unprecedented attacks on critical and
independent media from the
administration combined with attempts to
change internet rules in a way that will
also damage independent media and
whether it's our show or some other show
I mean really I don't obviously I'd love
for you to be supporting our show but we
need to be supporting alternatives to
corporate media right now even if it's
not the david pakman show and for many
of you it is and trust me if you looked
at my email for five minutes you'd
realize that many of the people watching
are not going to be the people
supporting the david pakman show
financially that's okay right because
we've got what's going on with net
neutrality we've got the supposed
opening up of libel lawsuits and calling
media outlets you don't like fake news
there's this sort of trifecta going on
people might see our show every day and
we're lucky enough to have the resources
right now for our studio and for
equipment and for staff and distribution
but there's a systemic attack going on
right now and the attack on net
neutrality is just part of it let's look
at the ways in which this trifecta is
working number one you've got the Trump
administration wanting more legal
options against media outlets they want
to go after media outlets that publish
leaks that were provided to them even if
they didn't actually obtain any
information secretly or illegally that
would be the crossing of a major red
line number two you've got the attempt
to rollback Obama era
net neutrality laws and number three
you've had the YouTube advertiser
boycott which has crushed us and has
been big ly beneficial for corporate
media and by the way what media outlets
started the YouTube advertiser boycott
Oh little media outlets like The Wall
Street Journal who they're publishing of
hyperbolic articles arguing that the
YouTube ad algorithm can't successfully
keep advertising off of racist and
offensive content so this is a
three-pronged attack against independent
media people
I don't think Pat are understanding the
serious seriousness of this that's why
we're talking about it almost weekly
yeah I think most folks on the right
would even agree that we have to keep
the net neutrality laws as if even if
you watch you know say Glenn Beck or
Alex Jones and you voted for Donald
Trump but the problem there is then
you've got fooled then you thought that
they've
maybe you've protectors of the current
net neutrality laws and you have no
recourse
absolutely bamboozled on every level if
you're interested in helping us fight
against this trifecta three-pronged
approach against independent media
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership patreon at patreon.com slash
david pakman show this is an important
time to help fund the programs that you
find valuable whether it's this one or
some other program this is the time